My name is Neerja Aggarwal and I was an electrical
engineering and theater arts major in my undergraduate here.
And now I’m studying electrical engineering
as a master’s student.
Last spring is when I started having discussions
about possibly directing Einstein’s Dreams.
It was my undergraduate theater thesis project.
The full spring production for MIT Theater
Arts this year was going to be directed by me,
which is a huge responsibility because it’s usually a role that’s taken on by faculty members or outside directors.
So I was both lucky and very empowered by
the entire theater department to take on this responsibility.
There were definitely times where I was not
making decisions fast enough or I wasn’t
really quite sure what I wanted, and there
was still a lot of learning on the job as
I went through.
I mean, MIT’s philosophy is Mens et Manus,
right?
So it’s Mind and Hand, and these were really
more growing opportunities, where you’re
working on a show, but you realize that you’re
learning life skills instead.
Einstein’s Dreams is about these different
worlds where time runs differently.
It explores the human ramifications of this
slight manipulation in time.
So imagine a world where our lifetimes just
are circular, they keep repeating themselves.
What effect does that have on the people living
out their lives in this circular time?
What effect does it have when they slowly
start to realize that they’re carrying out
the same loop over and over again, and they
can’t break out of it?
It’s also about Einstein’s creative journey
toward discovering special relativity.
So, in a way, it’s his thought experiments.
It’s him sitting down and thinking, “Ok,
well what if time worked like this?
Then what would happen?”
In this show, there’s not a single Einstein.
Anybody could be Einstein, because this role
is transitioning through all these three different
actresses.
Sabrine Iqbal, she’s a course 2 senior.
Alexa Garcia is a course 20 senior, and Alexandra
Boles, she’s studying political science
at Wellesley.
Probing deeper, I realized that for me, what
I was interested in was the cost of creativity,
the struggles, the frustrations, the obsessions
of the creative process,
and that’s what Einstein’s Dreams is also
about.
And that’s something I feel like we all
at MIT here can relate to.
Pretty much anything that’s open-ended and
creative and has never been done before, you
go through this very similar journey.
As a director, you’re leading the actors
but then you’re also collaborating with
all of the designers and leading that team,
talking back and forth, exchanging ideas,
you know, posing questions and seeing the response.
Your job really is to set the tone of the
room, and create a safe environment where
accidents can happen.
Because sometimes, you know, an accident is
the most brilliant part of a show.
In a way, directing a show is very similar
to doing research, and that’s interesting
because then you can use what you’ve learned
from one and apply it to the other.
So, for example, some tools and activities
that I’ve learned in directing — how to
brainstorm ideas, how to build off of a problem
statement, how to curate different ideas — I’ve
actually been able to use that in my graduate
research also, to help me think about problems,
how to break things down.
It’s really until you’re in the rehearsal
room, making decisions on the job, when you
actually learn what it is to make work with
a group of other people.
I decided I wanted to be an engineer because
I felt that being an engineer would give me
the skills and capabilities to work on really
difficult problems.
But people are also half of that equation,
so how do you communicate those results?
How do you turn that discovery into an impact?
That was my inspiration for studying both
engineering and theater here at MIT.